welcome to another dr sadler's honest
book review this is a series in which
i'm reviewing mostly recent books in
philosophy particularly
practical philosophy
extending all the way into things like
leadership and personal development and
self-help today we're going to be
looking at one that's solidly within you
could call it old-school
philosophy it's on truth by
simon blackburn published with oxford
university press back in 2018
and as usual i'll be telling you about
what i think is good about the book what
are the weak points or problematic
aspects giving you kind of an overview
and summary and i will say at the very
beginning and i'll say this again at the
end as well as we get to final thoughts
i
find the book
well written but also
you know kind of weak in certain respect
i think it could be a decent
springboard for studies but definitely
just that it's it's a starter book it is
not the definitive word
on the topic and so we'll find out why
in just a minute
we always begin with looking at three
s's style
structure and then a summary of what the
work is about because i think that is
very helpful for people diving into this
so let's start with style so blackburn
is a great writer
this is very readable he's not
dumbing things down in any way but it's
also quite approachable and i think
that's one of the
strengths of the work in blackburn's
writing
in general
um the structure right it's divided
basically into two parts there's after a
brief preface an introduction
part one is the classic approaches and
what do we mean by the classic
approaches well
now classic approaches towards the
theories or you know perspectives on
what truth itself is and he's going to
talk about um five main ones kind of
unevenly as we'll see in a moment and
there's a summary at the very end of it
and then part two is is quite
interesting varieties of inquiry and so
he's going to talk about how truth plays
out
outside of
we could say the realm of academic
abstract theorizing about truth and in
other places ranging from art to
religion to
law and and a variety of other things in
between there's um
a set of notes you know which are
essentially just endnotes there's a
useful index and one of the things
that's kind of interesting
he has a section back here called
further
investigations which
is
giving you some idea of where you could
go
after this if you want to read more
because this is a very slim volume you
know all the way back to the
further investigations and the notes
we've got 136 pages total
so you know not not an awful lot here
now um
we should say something about the
nature of the book itself right
so these these two different parts are
going to be treating
truth but in different ways
and
i will say this if you're familiar with
aj air's language truth and logic
of you know very early classic of
analytic philosophy in the 20th century
this book is kind of like that you know
it's beginning with some more general
examinations and reflections and
critiques and then it's looking at
specific issues and instances some of
the same ones religion
ethics you know and we're going to talk
about how
uh the deflationist theory which um
blackburn says that he has
some sympathy with is you know kind of
similar to some other things as well so
this is on page 63 and so this could be
part of the summary
the reader may detect i have some
considerable sympathies with
deflationism right he he comes right out
and says that and so we're gonna you
know look at what that is in just a
moment
um
he also tends to
talk quite a lot
about the need to get away from merely
abstract theorizing
and to
carry out our thinking or theorizing
in a way that's a bit
different
and
he says this this is in very deep in the
book in in the
last main chapter the moral of these
discussions is basically simple but i
hope sufficiently provocative to be
worth exa emphasizing
purse james bentham and others
constantly remind us of our actual
activities and actual motivations and
cares we only have the language the
resources of thought that we do because
some activities have proved useful or
essential
these activities include trying to
thrash things out trying to warp our own
heritage of beliefs and dispositions as
little as possible in order to
accommodate the problems that friction
with the world throws up
the language of truth reason
justification knowledge certainty and
doubt is our instrument for discussing
all this
this language is used in the same way in
connection with any subject matter even
as we have seen those where truth has
proved especially elusive and contested
such as ethics
and aesthetics right so that i think
that gives you an idea about
you know his general approach
in the book and if we're going to have a
overall summary
what blackburn is doing is
looking at a selected number of
sort of standard approaches to truth
and trying to look at their pros and
cons their strengths and weaknesses
and then shifting
to looking at the issue of truth
um and you know the many other connected
things justification how we argue with
each other in a variety of messy or
stickier
domains
of existence
so that's
that's probably going to give you a good
idea about what the book is about and
what the book is like
we should talk now about some of the
main points and key ideas that are being
put forth in the work and we'll also hit
on
blackburn's motivations and approach in
this and i think a good place to start
is the introduction
which begins very interestingly
situating this book within a
historical and cultural
situation so
he says this is the very first sentence
in 2016 the blyth mendacity and sheer
carelessness with facts indulged by
politicians and british and america gave
rise to the idea we somehow live in a
post-truth environment this was
canonized when oxford dictionaries
chosen
as the word of the year defining it as
an adjective relating to or denoting
circumstances in which objective facts
are less influential in shaping public
opinion than appeals to emotion and
personal belief and he brings up donald
trump and and
his counselor kellyanne conway and then
goes back to talking about machiavelli's
the prince and
talks about you know various
prime ministers george orwell's
horrendous vision of a totalitarian
totalitarian control of the truth in
1984 it goes on you know quite a bit but
you get the idea
we live in a time
when people are not taking truth as
seriously
as they ought to be and so you know it
could be good for us to get some sense
of what truth is and if we go to the
very end of that
he says
thinking we're post anything implies
nostalgia for a past that might itself
be
mythological a little bit further down
he says
there have been philosophers who claim
to be skeptical about the very concept
of truth often it turns out they're
really skeptical either about our own
prospects of getting added in some
domain or another worried about the
status of the powers that lead us to
offer one interpretation or another of
things
and then he he goes down and this is the
last paragraph the basic reason why the
concept of truth will never die
is that to believe anything at all is to
take a stand on its truth and we cannot
do without belief since planning and
acting in the world
requires that these are the defenses i
develop in this little essay
showing why even in highly contested
areas the concept of truth is a survivor
so i mean that's a great
line right there essay right
this is not a comprehensive overview
of theories of truth this is a weaving
through them to try to get to some sort
of point
um in the very beginning of part one he
also tells us something that i think is
pretty
pretty accurate there is an air of
divinity that hangs over the concept of
truth
truth is the goal of inquiry the aim of
experiment the standard signaling the
difference between it being right to
believe something and wrong to do so and
you know he goes that isn't so truth is
clearly something that even those of us
who say oh we're post-truth or you know
truth is is tied in with uh precious
power
everyone
has some sort of connection to truth
and you know like somebody who
blackburn doesn't actually bring up
that matina says everybody wants to
actually be in contact with the truth
nobody wants to be deceived or lied to
uh you know and so there's there's
something there's a sticking power to
truth and then we have to ask ourselves
well how are we going to make sense of
this and this is where the chapters come
in with these classic approaches
so
if you've ever taken an intro to
philosophy class or looked at you know
sort of a
typical
overview video about truth you'll hear
these three
common theories being talked about
correspondence
coherence
pragmatists and then you might get a mix
of a few other things blackburn is going
to talk about the deflationist
conception of truth and a semantic
conception of truth adding those to the
mix
and you know correspondence theory of
truth is basically
you know that truth is and there's a lot
of different formulations
uh when are our thoughts or our language
correspond to
facts or the reality or how things are
out there and there's some problems with
that of course what about things that
are
referential like this statement is a
true statement you know it's not
corresponding to something out in the
world it's language relating to itself
or thought relating to itself then we
could go on and on and on
and so there's a discussion in here you
know about the correspondence theory
of truth and then you know a lot of
um
criticisms worries about
whether this could be an adequate
conception of truth
and you know it's not a very long um
overview it's
really just 10 pages
um but it at least gives you some idea
about what's going on there uh you know
then we move to the coherence theory of
truth which is usually the next place we
go in an intro class or talking about
these topics and a coherence theory of
truth says that truth is not in the
correspondence between these things but
rather in the beliefs or statements or
however we want to frame it
being logically coherent with each other
something that doesn't fit in with our
however you want to call it web of
belief background notions uh the you
know the absolute and all of its its uh
frameworks but all of its manifestations
whatever it doesn't fit in with that is
false
and we figure things out by comparing
them to each other in that way and
blackburn points out that you know this
works for some things just as the
you know correspondence theory works for
some things
and he says something really quite
interesting here
though coherence theory of truth gained
a strong following in the 19th century
partly due to the influence of kant and
hegel and especially in the thought of
british
philosophers influenced by them known as
british idealists one of its
implications is beliefs do not belong to
whole systems in the way that pebbles
lie on the beach disconnected from each
other and independent of their neighbors
rather they belong organically to whole
systems or theories of the world in the
way that a hand belongs to an arm or an
arm to a body the interlocking system
has the character of a living body an
organic hole in which each part gains
its value precisely by being a part of
the whole
and he says this idea called the holism
of belief systems diverts attention from
the single sentence expressing a single
truth to whole theories or systems of
beliefs and that's that's quite true and
then he points out i think this is
actually quite quite correct
in 19th century hands the coherence
theory had a semi-religious flavor ideal
coherence it was thought could belong
only to the thoughts of an infinite mind
a mind capable of encompassing an
infinitive interlocking beliefs somewhat
like god's mind which the idealists
christened the
absolutes and and so you know he talks
about that then he points out some of
the
problems with the coherence theory of
truth as well you know he says
coherences have often faltered but
trying to explain the importance of
control by observation
over impressed by the omnipresence of
interpretation they've jumped to the
conclusion that
nothing can count as a reason for
holding a belief except another belief
this is problematic
this is actually you know uh
a decent uh treatment then he has a
chapter on pragmatism and notice that uh
each of these is not framed as the you
know the corresponding theory of truth
the pragmatic theory of truth it's just
pragmatism
and
what's really quite interesting about
this is he tells us that and i think a
lot of other people kind of suspect this
as well
maybe the pragmatist theory of truth is
not
something
totally separate from these other two
it's really
kind of a coherence theory of truth but
taken to
another
level you could say
so um
he says it this way
american pragmatism is not a rival to
coherentism but an elaboration of it
adding the dimension of success in
action and inquiry so it's sort of like
a you know
coherence theory of truth with some
extra parts and stuff like that
and there's you know a good discussion
in here about
the limits of a pragmatic theory of
truth ultimately getting to talking
about richard rorty
and a lot of stuff here from james he
does mention a little bit of so it's not
totally american pragmatism that
mentions a little bit of nietzsche
but doesn't go into it too
much
and then we get to
stuff that goes beyond the usual
textbook treatments we have deflationism
which again
is the the theory or approach or
perspective that blackburn says he
he has a lot of sympathy with
and deflationism like he says starts
with an observation that makes no
difference whether we simply assert
something or asserted prefacing the
assertion with it is true that so he
talks about this transparency property
meaning that like you see through it
saying that something is true is not
really
saying anything about the statement
that's other than like i i like this
this this makes sense to me and stuff
like that so he says deflationism is the
view about truth that celebrates
its transparency the core
is the idea that once you understand the
transparency property you understand all
you need about what truth is truth is
kind of a dress version of the grunt
of a set there are some bells and
whistles to add to this core if the
notion of truth never added anything to
what is given by making assertion it
would be entirely redundant
and so he says you know well what what
is the
add-on and he goes into you know a few
things about that but the deflationist
um
viewpoint or perspective is you could
say
unmasking
or
you know taking away the
importance that we've been assigning to
truth in the past and he also you know
looks at um
whether there's any any problems with it
he says
um
you
know
it seems like it could be
refuted but actually it's not that easy
to do that um you know and he uses the
the success of science as an example
and he says um you know we have to be
careful with all of these things just to
focus on
how we do how we use these these
ideas and expressions in
ordinary life
and uh you know this is actually quite a
extensive section so you know you can
tell
where
um
where uh
blackburn is is placing the emphasis so
this is 15 pages compared to the others
and then we get this short chapter on
tarsky and the semantic theory of truth
the semantic theory of truth is
basically trying to carry out something
like the logist project
did
and to give you know formally correct
definition of the true sentences of a
language easy to talk about tarsky here
in particular and you know this is quite
interesting to read i don't think the
ordinary person is going to get that
much out of this compared to the
previous ones and it's essentially an
attempt to try to
take natural language
and
determine what would actually count as
truth from a purely logical
formal logic perspective
it's the sort of thing that not only
tarsky was doing but also copy in some
of his books besides the textbooks that
he had so that's that's the first part
of this then we get to the second part
varieties of inquiry and this is quite
interesting because he begins with
aesthetics truths of taste truth in art
and he does point out that you know
we we don't say that it truly is
anything goes anybody can interpret
anything anyway we say that
there are practices of criticism and so
then the question is well
are the critics in touch with truth in a
way that we ourselves aren't
and you know he kind of shows his hand
here there's going to be a lot of david
hume being brought up in this second
section
and this is uh the very start of it if
you've ever you know read
some of hume's essays you'll recognize
um you know where this is this stuff is
coming from
um
and then he finishes up by talking about
collingwood's
you know the great british
philosopher collingwood's what is
art
and um you know trying to not reduce our
aesthetic response to mere emotion but
say that there could be something
there that actually counts as truth
in the truth and ethics section we're
gonna see
a lot of hume a lot of more
a little bit of purse being discussed
and then you know the contrast is going
to be
um
to adam smith who you know is a
contemporary human in some respects is
adding something to the picture
and um
you know
he's starting with more in kind of a an
interesting way
kind of an eccentric way as well because
moore was famously trying to dissociate
ethics from anything that had a
naturalistic basis
including a lot of other things and then
hume is brought back in to
allow us to do that there's a lot of
attention being paid there
to um
uh hume's ethical theory which is worth
knowing but is is a kind of strange
place to go
um and then we get adam smith um you
know here's a great example here
um
adam smith departed from hume smith
thought that anger and resentment were
natural reactions to causes by trespass
from another
um you know smith's rejection of the way
in which hume's conception of justice
was wedded to antecedent conventions was
taken up and expanded by kant who saw
respect for each other as a more
important foundation stone than the
straightforward pursuit of goods and
avoidance of evil or satisfactions
resulting from this
so that's
you know that's that's what's going on
in that chapter then we have a chapter
that's just simply titled reason which
really has to do much more with action
theory and isn't about
reason as such it's about
reasonings and it's about giving reasons
for and whether these can be said to be
true or false and what what it would
take for that there's a little bit of a
uh detour into talking about philosophy
of science and then we come right back
to
uh philosophy of action you know here's
a great example we can discuss which
movements of the mind are reasonable or
unreasonable in this much the same way
as we can discuss which motivations and
behaviors are admirable or compulsory or
impermissible you know and he says he
points out to you that much of our
reasoning is automatic and implicit
you know but we can we can look at that
and this is a very short section
then we have a section on religion and
truth and here
you know the main people that he's
actually talking about he begins with
talking about durkheim
and then it's hobbs more hume of course
uh you know considering stuff from his
dialogues concerning natural religion
there's actually a good bit of like
summarizing what's going on there
and
you know that's about it except for this
he says might religions be accorded the
same generosity we earlier gave to
aesthetics and ethics there we turn from
bothering about the concept of truth in
the abstract to describing and generally
speaking encouraging the practices of
the inquirer and the critic
and so he goes and he says
couldn't we just say that there's
religious practices including those of
inquiry and discussion that can be
regarded both as attempts to know how to
improve our awareness and attitudes
towards the universe and
try and try and as trying to find
religious truth
and he goes on and he says it's not a
bad suggestion
there may be some religious practices
and attitudes to which it is uh
well fitted
but yeah religions are also a way of
turning up the volume he says
a dissenter is not a voice to be
accommodated a fellow inquirer in a
serious attempt to lay doubt with whom
we may come to be one-minded about
things but someone to be shunned or
exterporated on a thema sit let it be
damned
so looking at the way in which religions
implement themselves it would be naive
to be too optimistic right and then he
says by the way this also applies to
politics
as well and then we have a final
discussion of interpretations
which is he does mention history but
it's really about law and it's about how
we can
i mean it talks about interpretive
disciplines but it's really mostly
about
argument about what the law
says or what the law
is and whether truth and falsity are to
be
found
there in in these interpretations and
then we're then we're done that's the
entire book
you know again very short text
so what's good about this little book
you know what does get discussed
because there's a lot of things that
aren't getting discussed often is quite
decent as i mentioned blackburn is a
good writer and you know good thinker
and it's good it's fun to go along on
the ride with him i do like the fact
that he
presents uh theories or perspectives on
truth both you know as what truth is and
also how it would be applied in things
and then goes on to
critique them that's kind of nice
it could be as i said a good springboard
for study of of matters of truth um if
it you know sort of the proverbial
ladder that you climb up and then throw
away i think that's perfectly fine and i
will say that i i you know i did like
the second half uh quite a bit better
than the first half um
as a matter of fact
um i i kind of like this this idea he
brings this up in
the section truths of taste truth of art
um the application of our discussions in
part one enables us to understand the
point of person's advice
not to start with vagabond ideas that
have no human habitation but with men in
their
conversation um if we thought of
aesthetic truth as some kind of
abstraction
uh you know a bloodless property
distributed who knows how among the
things in our universe it would be hard
to see the point of coming to
discriminate so i like this this idea
that we we do need to remain closer to
our lived reality our interpersonal
reality
um and you could call this a usefulness
of not focusing in
solely on truth in the abstract but
always looking at that particularity
and i will say this um
[Music]
most of the people that he mentions
um
blackburn is on point and getting things
right in talking about them so i i think
that you know that's that's a good
feature of the book
as well you know in a book on truth you
definitely want
truthfulness and i will say that there's
you know there's a good bit of it here
in this book
i did find an awful lot in this work
that to me seems problematic
and
in some cases
i would say even
perhaps irresponsible
as an author now
you could try to deflect these by saying
well
again he's not trying to provide you
with an overview of truth as such or
engage every single author throughout
history he's just writing an essay in
our post-truth times that's supposed to
help out i don't really buy that line of
reasoning
and
he i think it'll become clear as i talk
about some of the things that i thought
were
problematic i mean there are some cases
where he's just getting things wrong
in a way that strikes me as kind of
irresponsible for a philosopher
so
here's one prime example
some classical moralist notably the
stoics sometimes make it seem as though
having desires and aversions at all
is a regrettable feature of the human
condition and one that we should try as
hard as possible to suppress and then he
talks about kant is
showing a degree of sympathy with his
harsh view
and you know he goes out a little bit
more and he says neither hume nor smith
had much sympathy with his stoic
ambition in general
and when he says that you're like yeah
you know this is he hasn't read the
stoics he's he's basically taking this
from later authors who've got the stoics
wrong i mean all you got to do is read
epictetus
and coridian chapter one
to realize that
aversion and desire are the things that
are under control and we should try to
withdraw them from external but that
doesn't mean that we like suppress them
or don't apply them to ourselves and so
that's just a you know a bad read
and you know some editor should have
caught that or blackberry should have
should have known better and so that
should like put you on guard a little
bit
i will say
you know the other authors who he brings
up he's generally getting right but
you know there's some problems there
another really big problem with this
book
it
it's very parochial in a way it ignores
much of the vast literature
out there
from ancient times onward forward
about truth so i mean how do you write a
book on truth
and i mean it doesn't mention aristotle
but he doesn't mention the thing that
would be most germane nick mccain ethics
book
six right
i mean there's other stuff in aristotle
that would be important but aristotle
makes a distinction between
theoretical and practical truth and
elaborates it
and it's right there and and blackburn
seems completely um
it's like something totally unknown to
you he does bring up some other
aristotle stuff
but misses the opportunity
he mentioned nietzsche
doesn't tell you anything about what
nietzsche's ideas about truth were and
nietzsche is an important author in this
conversation
i don't know how you bring up theories
of truth
and try to be you know comprehensive
and ignore
say heidegger and the concept of truth
is all of theia
massively important you know i don't
know how you
talk about applications of truth and
ignore a lot of the discussions in you
know the whole of 20th century
philosophy of the relations between
truth and power especially we're going
to talk in a post-truth world
there's other authors who he misses
along the way i mean the correspondence
theory should have had a discussion of
aquinas at the very least
or a van some who aquinas's theory of
truth is dependent upon who's got a
whole book called on
truth in which he lays out truth in you
know the mind in expression also in
going back to the practical stuff right
the will
action the being of things
even if he was just going to reject it
blackburn should have
brought those up and i think it's
because he doesn't know these these uh
authors
you know or doesn't know them well
um you know we could bring up sextus
empiricus and his many very interesting
discussions we go on and on and on and
on about ideas of truth that somehow
weren't good enough or didn't make it
into this and they are actually good
enough and they should have had some
mention at least instead what gets
mentioned is the authors that blackburn
clearly is engaged with um and
you know really nobody else
um
as we mentioned earlier you know
blackburn says that
he has
some sympathy with the deflationist view
and i kind of think that the
deflationist view
is similar to what we call emotivism
in ethics which reduces
um
you know whatever would be true in
ethical statements just to emotive
matters you know or to trying to coerce
somebody else
i i mean i understand this could be
contestable somebody's going to point
out that's not what the deflation is
saying but there's there's an analogy
there that i think is well worth picking
out i also myself um
see kind of an analogy between the
people who follow content saying
existence or reality is not a predicate
and what the deflationist
view on truth is doing
as well
i think that and here's my last
criticism i think that blackbird so one
of the strengths of his work is also a
weakness
he's right in that we should avoid like
abstract theorizing for its own sake
and we should be focusing on language
practices
on the cares and concerns of human being
and how truth figures into that the
trouble is is that blackburn has picked
a very narrow and rather parochial
group of humans to do that with
um
not just academic philosophers but you
could say people of a certain
type who take themselves as being like
the universal voices
of human beings
there's
there's so much that doesn't there's so
many voices so many concerns so many uh
ways of looking at things that don't
even get
brought in
into
not even into discussion
about this it's very much a
i want to i'm not going to say ivory
tower because i don't really like that
metaphor there's a little falsity to it
but it is an elite group discussion an
elite group that's essentially you know
upper middle class to middle class
affiliated with universities reading the
right kind of things you know
living in the right areas having the
right discussions and leaving everybody
else
out of the picture i would say
you know and this doesn't just apply to
like say thinking about race or class or
gender in the present i mean all the
people of the past
you know the western tradition that he
has just ignored as important voices or
reduced to a sound bite
i'd say that they're left out of the
conversation as well and all of us in
the present who read them and think
about them
so it's an
unsatisfying book in in many respects
those are my my criticisms those are the
things i thought were problematic about
the work
so my final thoughts on simon
blackburn's on truth um you know it's
not bad it's not particularly
good it's kind of in between
um if you like
easy breezy but still you know on point
writing
it's got a good style
as i said before it could be a decent
springboard
starting looking into this and it's nice
that he gives you some other places to
go but they're all kind of the same
stuff as what what he's doing
so
you know it's um i'm giving it a
qualified endorsement it's the kind of
book that i would say
maybe don't buy as such but get from
your local library i mean it is very
inexpensive as a book and if you like
having this sort of thing not no reason
not to buy it but
it's that the sort of thing that's a
quick read you know and you can get it
probably
anywhere in a local library or you can
sit around in a bookstore and read your
way through it as well and
that's
that's my recommendation
you